Mount Westmore the album uh it comes out
Friday
um I'm very excited this is I'm so glad
you guys put this together I'm so glad
it's actually coming out because I
really I didn't believe it was gonna
happen until y'all did the trailer [ __ ]
and then that song came out and then it
was quiet and I was like ah at least we
got one record you know yeah well
uh now you could like not believe that
the second album is coming out so there
was plans to do a second now
is this all happening at the compound at
Snoop spot like were you guys recording
we did it all over the studio so and we
might add a few more new ones to us you
know what I mean because we we and we in
that mode it's easy it's so simple I can
tell you personally you know second
album is dope as [ __ ] it's hard slaps
it's hard for us to make a bad record
together I mean you got it yeah of
course so we got to kind of work hard
to make a bad record did you guys try to
kick the Dr Dre tree to get a beat or
something like one of those millions of
detox songs that he didn't uh doesn't
ever plan on releasing I think I think
Dr Dre is the greatest producer in
hip-hop of all time one of them I think
sometimes we can overthink you know you
know when we play dominoes we play we
say steady wrong steady long steady
wrong we need when you take too long to
play your dominoes right
I'm not saying he's steady wrong it's
just he's a perfectionist and I raise on
the album he is on here he intros one of
his songs yeah he does well that's all
that matters but we I think we're going
to get a song out of Dre I think he's
just gonna get a few We Love Drake you
know it's the only song well I mean you
know what I was gonna say I forgot about
like
you but I think I in like Peak like 90s
hip-hop like it was was it only natural
born killers that y'all did together
like after NWA happened Natural Born
Killers we did because
yeah hello
what about the new NWA hello was a slap
hello
yo what's yeah how close were y'all to
doing the [ __ ] new NWA with Snoop was
that like how where are those songs at
not close at all he's like you heard the
songs they came out it is we were about
to get into it and then he he met Eminem
and then he met he met uh 50 and it was
like because chin check was fire yeah he
met he met those two dudes and that just
took his attention all right I mean
listen Andrea is a genius hopefully we
get something out of him well the album
he's been sending me a lot of money it
was an early on Mount Westmore supporter
he got caught wind of the project early
through Snoop he pulled up the Snoop
Studio he put a stamp of approve on he
jumped on the phone oh we got a song
with him but it's not it didn't make
this out I'll be on the second half